well we were promised transparency on
day one of the biden white house but as
the press demands access to the
unprecedented situation at the border
they continue to be denied we'll always
be honest and transparent with you about
both the good news and the bad
if you all wanted to grant access to the
press
couldn't you just tell dhs to do it
again we fully support transparency and
i would encourage you to talk to the
department of homeland security about
any requests you have
we're working on providing footage so
that the american public
can see the border patrol stations the
border is secure
the border is closed we're working
on providing footage what a stunning
statement right there senior writer for
townhall.com
julio rosas will be on the ground
visiting the texas border this week and
he joins me now
let's start right there julio there are
reportedly
very little uh allowances for the press
to get in there and see what's happening
at the border but don't worry because
the bite administration is going to
provide
you some footage but they're working on
it but they will eventually provide you
some footage you think that will satisfy
your curiosity julio
no and and in fact i was supposed to go
visit the carrizo springs facility for
unaccompanied minors
and it was all set up through
congressman roy's office and i was given
the green light
and once we got there we we were
starting to be processed to be let in we
were had our temperature checked we
had a medical grade face mask be issued
to us and we're just waiting to get our
covet test because that's what the
administration has been using as a
pretext to bar
press uh is because of cover
restrictions uh but then they found out
we were members of the press and we were
immediately denied and were separated
from roy's party and we had to leave
and so it is kind of interesting that
they are using kobit 19
as a pretext to keep press out but it
appears that members of congress and
their staff are still able to tour the
facility
so let me see if i understand that
correctly julio you were part of a
congressional delegation a media member
part of the congressional delegation you
were carved out of the touring party
reportedly or what they told you for
covered
protective reasons but then they let the
congressional delegation go on they were
allowed to continue the tour but the
media were the ones
that they had to protect from covid
problems
right and and look it's pretty obvious
why the administration doesn't
want members of the press to document
for themselves what's happening in these
facilities and
and elsewhere along the border is just
simply because this is a crisis and
what makes it worse is that this is a
self-inflicted crisis uh this this
didn't need to happen but because of the
open border rhetoric and policies that
we've seen from this administration it
has incentivized
uh this massive surge it's not the only
reason why but it is
a big reason and i can say that i uh
just last october i was with acting
commissioner mark morgan
uh doing a ride-along with him and so
even in the age of covet
ride-alongs with border patrol is still
possible and yet that's not being
allowed right now
so we said at the beginning of this
segment julio you're headed back to the
border next week
this is potentially at least what you'll
see in numbers here's the increase in
adult quote encounters that's the new
term
under the biden administration
encounters up 188 percent
unaccompanied minors up 92 percent what
are you expecting to see
not just in the numbers but with your
own eyes next week
well unfortunately we're going to
continue seeing uh unaccompanied minors
and family units because the
the the department of homeland security
secretary has said that
they're not going to deport uh those
types of groups uh like they used to be
like they used to and so that again
that's incentivizing
uh human trafficking among the most
vulnerable groups unaccompanied minors i
mean the cartels aren't doing this
out of the kindness of their hearts and
they take advantage of the people they
traffic especially the miners and so
what i saw two weeks ago and what i
expect to see this week is
mostly unaccompanied minors and and
family units and that this is like i
said this is a crisis
yeah and you're right along this coming
week is with the hidalgo county
constable
so you should get some access to see
exactly what's happening down there
we'd love to talk to you afterwards
julio thanks for giving us a preview
this morning on fox and friends thank
you take care